now former cia station chief dan hoffman
former speaker of the house newt
gingrich both fox news contributors mr
speaker there is a clear distinction
only north touched on it the trump plan
was based going to be based on
conditions on the ground factor number
one factor number two
is
donald trump was believed if donald
trump made a threat they believed it
because he had a track record while
while isis grew
under biden and obama isis was
systematically destroyed and defeated
under donald trump he said it he did it
and the taliban knew damn well what
would happen if in fact they didn't
abide by any agreement that went on they
wouldn't have tried this under trump
would be my argument your thoughts
well look i mean first of all i don't
know that joe biden has threatened
anybody with anything
so there's no way of knowing
the biden worldview seems to be
attack your allies
ignore your enemies
uh pretend that bad things aren't
happening i mean i watched this speech
this afternoon and i thought
if you for most people if you took what
you were seeing live coming out of
afghanistan
uh the crowds the fear the takeover by
the taliban and then you looked at this
speech by this guy who was clearly
totally out of it
he has no idea what's going on and his
number one goal in that speech was to
blame anybody else he said you know the
buck stops here he didn't mean that uh
the buck stopped with the afghan army
the bucks stopped with donald trump the
book stops somewhere else but the fact
is this is a major american defeat is
going to have huge consequences as you
pointed out earlier it's going to
embolden the chinese whether it's in
taiwan or the south china sea or frankly
they're going to become allies of the
taliban
because they want the minerals in which
northern afghanistan is enormously rich
and they're going to be quite happy they
don't care what the taliban does to
women they just want the minerals
as recently as last thursday dan hoffman
and you worked all these years in the
intelligence community they were telling
us oh at best they didn't they wouldn't
make it to kabul for another 90 days at
least
on every level how could they have been
so wrong
how could joe biden just a couple of
weeks ago be saying oh there's no it'll
never happen the taliban will never be
able to get back in power
and yet now they
now it is the what you know emirates of
afghanistan here we go
i mean islamic immigration
wishful
yeah it's aspirational wishful foreign
policy uh just as the administration
administration was arguing that if the
taliban wanted to receive international
recognition and foreign aid that they
wouldn't attempt to take over the
country by force well that ignored the
reality that china and russia
not to mention iran and pakistan are
going to support
the taliban we our greatest ally in that
region was the former government of
afghanistan and what really concerns me
going forward is that we used to own the
battle space and we had a sizable
intelligence community footprint so when
we uh served our mission to find and fix
those terrorists so we could detect and
preempt threats we had the kinetic
capability to preempt them before they
were visited on our shores we don't have
that anymore and the taliban controls
the country so what i wanted to hear
today and what i hope we hear soon from
the byte administration is what's the
plan to deal with those threats we're a
few weeks out from the 20th anniversary
of of 9 11 and irony of ironies we are
at greater risk now from afghanistan
than we ever have been before
mr speaker we got 10 000 americans there
and we're not in control of that country
or that airport how are they going to
get those americans home
well i think mostly garage to get out of
there but it's very disturbing that
apparently administration announced
yesterday americans wouldn't be
automatically given any kind of priority
uh which is the opposite of the policy
we've always had up until now but you
know i think there's a deeper thing here
the taliban
has been around for a long time they've
had a set of goals they are a religious
fanatic group they're going what's going
to happen to women and president george
w bush was exactly right today to say
that the greatest thing he fears is
what's going to happen to young girls
and to women
and as you may remember when klister was
the ambassador of the vatican she hosted
a conference on religious liberty we had
a young woman from iraq who had been
captured by isis and had been basically
passed around as a slave
that's the kind of stuff we're going to
see in afghanistan and it's sad that not
a single women's group on the left is up
in arms over what's about to happen
we're going to pick up on that on the
other side of this mr speaker thank you
dan hoffman thank you hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else